welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by Squarespace all right listen to me
create a beautiful website turn your
cool idea into a new website you can
showcase your work your blog you can
publish content on there you can sell
products and services of all kinds and
promote your physical and online
business you can announce an upcoming
event the special project and a lot more
listen head over to squarespace.com for
a free trial when you're ready to launch
use the offer code Church to save your
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain that squarespace.com now I
said when you're ready to launch the
time is now you've been thinking about
this even wanting to do it the time is
now it's today go to squarespace.com
right now enter church and get 10% off
your first purchase and let's get this
idea flowing alright cuz it's been
sitting in your brain forever and nobody
else is gonna push it like your uncle
Joey number two you know what I'd love
to shave in the shadow figure is I was
one of these [ __ ] MOOCs that Shane
after you brush your teeth and then you
cut yourself eighty two [ __ ] yeah
you're going to shower you put the steam
on later but here plugs on next thing
you know your shave it's like butter if
I'm whipped
beautiful you know what I love to shave
cuz I use Harry's that's why it's
beautiful to blade the shave the
comfortable glide model dummy you won't
believe how nice of this little one
Harry's is doing for you right now how
are you so confident you're gonna love
their blades they're gonna give you a
trial shave set for free that's how
uncle Joey works it free gratis nothing
on the arm I'm all doomed for free when
you sign up in harrys.com slash Church
and you're just gonna pay for shipping
that's it
claim your free trial offer from Harry's
today their team dollar value for free
when you sign up just for cover shipping
I'm gonna send your Wayne an ergonomic
razor handle five precision blades
rich lathering shave gel and you ready
for this one a travel blade cover who's
better than uncle Joey you come on to
get your free trial
go to harrys.com slash Church right now
that's harrys.com slash church Lee stick
a finger that meals as it's Wednesday
[ __ ] drop like [ __ ] is on a
Thursday I think is what you want to get
up and swing dick oh you want to what
get up and walk around like a [ __ ]
Zombo like every day it's the Church of
what's happened now [ __ ] with my
little brother Sammy trips and my other
little brother [ __ ] the [ __ ] man
Christ killer last week Lee and I was
sitting here after a podcast on to the
guild is that something that he had done
Richard please shows blah blah blah he
goes you know man I got to tell you
tripolis a bit crazy but he's a really
good guy go you know what man call him
what you want
he's been here for 20 years swinging
like Pete Rose diving you know some
people sometimes people show for a while
he had chicks on stage a [ __ ] on a
bicycle that poor kid they made him lose
a hundred pounds in the bunny suit you
broke that book kid that [ __ ]
will left here like old Benjamin lost
100 pounds stopped drinking he was
selling souvenirs and Hollywood he just
broke that yeah where is he I don't know
man he got mad at me for a while I don't
know dude no he took it silly he went to
[ __ ] like psychiatry
you know some dudes go deep so like you
go deep and you come back some people
don't come back I respect the [ __ ] out
of guys like you in this town I respect
the [ __ ] out of comics that have stayed
pure to their game cuz every one
somewhere you see like a good friend of
your comic ah but I was doing director
film and you know here's another one
yeah straight a humble reservation the
humble brag that's not going nowhere
other words he's telling you I'm not
gonna do comedy no more because I'm
gonna do this I'm not gonna put that
much focus on it because you gave up you
saw what the [ __ ] this war was about
this is [ __ ] Apocalypse Now
yes dawg this is Apocalypse Now I am
sick and [ __ ] tired of people
thinking that you just stroll
- [ __ ] California and they hand you a
spot at the store you ready say Idol 5
like who the [ __ ] you yeah you have
to dog it out here you know the best
thing I ever did the last 10 years for
myself was go to that fourth wall with
Lisa al I think I'm every [ __ ] day
because the record made a meet it made
me even more of a Jew like it may be the
word because it remembered what it felt
like when you lived in Vegas be in the
trends you forget like you forgot about
it yeah go to like a string G open mic
where there's no booze nothing look at
their hearts look at their eyes and go
this used to be me yeah thinking of
being where I am today
yeah Amy yeah sitting in a room with six
of those guys going you know what
out of us six it's gonna be me in 20
years that takes [ __ ] balls and
persistence and I called you like a
lunatic as high as I get that last
family what high as [ __ ] and I go you
know what bro you crazy but you're still
here yeah cuz I know a lot of people
that came into this town that we're
gonna light this time on fire with
reputations but thank God and I saw I
see a lot of people I got fake
reputation as because listen these
people that you see in ho-ho and he they
ain't at the store hand-to-hand combat
yeah you know the improv is a great club
in a great chain the Laugh Factory is a
great club in a great chain but get
caught up but the comedies on a Tuesday
night behind Chris D'Elia I have to
Bobby Lee won on stage and you're
[ __ ] high through this [ __ ] savage
on stage and what the original rooms are
dude how long did you do seven minutes I
think it was like first of all I hate we
have to know I was like it was and I
tried to talk about it and the crowd
didn't like it like I was trying to get
a little sentimental at the beginning
because that I came there before I even
they did you know no they liked me they
liked me when I did when I didn't and up
when I when I was doing when I said
started doing jokes but they like I was
I went up and I started star I was just
like hey man this is really cool for me
like I this might my first time at the
store I've been I came here as a tourist
and they it was a silent like it wasn't
good
but then I went in and I started well
there's a few jokes that I haven't I was
[ __ ] up I was kind of high so haven't
like I think it like maybe half to three
quarters with the jokes and the other
and the rest of it was a little I was a
little high which the church people love
but it was a year loved it was like whoa
you know of course in most live one of
the most loved dudes I know when you get
on stage you're really
it's funny what happens to comedians
when they see somebody else on stage
like now you're a marine didn't say like
if I don't know you and I walked into a
place and I see you in a Chinese
restaurant dying on stage when you walk
off that stage I'm gonna shake it yeah
nobody else I'm gonna really shake your
hand go I've been there right I know
what it is to go onstage from people
eating and they won't look at you and
like I don't know what abuse is and I
was trying to say that but I liked that
I didn't get like I didn't want I get
like the stores pretty cool and I know I
I didn't want anyone like the door door
guys your young comics to think who've
been doing it for years longer than me
that I was taking that like that
opportunity for granted didn't know it
was just it was a I don't think anyone
would ever think that it was it was one
of the coolest experiences of my life
like it was a I'm glad I got to do
Austen a few weeks ago because that one
was really crazy no like it was
different kind of crazy there was I
think I'm probably a few more people
there
she said the bigger room but and I was
talking I was at first I thought it
might freak me out but we looked to the
side and there were two of the guys from
the fourth wall literally like the first
row on the stage right to the side of me
and I even said I hope she Derrick's
here it made me feel kind of almost at
home like it made me feel safer feel
like those two guys were there magically
for you and and they know they they took
the ride I I [ __ ] up I was when I was
high and it this was a little scary when
you kind of like blank on what you
wanted to say oh yeah and it's and it
looks obvious like I don't have the
skills yet till it kind of make it seem
like I didn't blink
and I forgot but then it was kind of
cool because it can't like I remembered
later in the set and
might have been the biggest laugh of the
night when I said oh that's why I
brought that up and they went crazy so
that it would it was just a did you like
shake was your heartbeat oh my heart was
beating for like pukin did you well I
don't know so you know I mean I just
wanna though I here's the thing what you
were thinking I don't know what exactly
how much of what is to blame but I had a
really terrible
uber drive down there like I was doing
like 45 down in Laurel Canyon so I
thought it's gonna get sick I didn't
think I was gonna be able to go on but
then when people started getting there
they were like oh that's just because
you're doing the store I was like oh
well dude a couple things I've heard do
you say I just want to give you a
congratulations on the thing about the
Oh ours that you have to be so much in
the moment the fact that you just talked
and recognized your friend and then you
go back you're like ah that's wise
bringing that up that is what that room
is I've watched that room humble
everybody Dave Attell Daniel Tosh
everybody seemed one person ever go in
there and it was their first time doing
it or at least the first time I'd seen
them do it and they did well and the god
dies through the only person I've ever
seen do it is Sarah Silverman and she
filed capper ello during his [ __ ] when
he was like his his his star was at its
brightest and I was blown away by how
well she went up there cuz I had never
seen her and I'd been at the store for
about five or six years night in and
night out she went in there so the fact
he went up there and he ate it a little
bit that is that that is the basically
the ritual that we all have to go
through you know the jump in that
becomes the o.r where you just have to
go through it to get to it man I've
liked the fact that you got to laugh and
put you ahead of people I know who I
have a lot Eric cater his first set
there what 15 minutes not one audible
reaction to anything he said it's so fun
to watch and now he's a great comic so
that's nothing together but you just
brought my life's in a thousand times
when you go somewhere with way down when
you go somewhere for a weekend and you
have a great five sets with somebody
with Rogen with Ari and on a Sunday you
go home you took a nap you feeling good
you don't mean to Denver's store and you
go up there with the same material
rebate
and you will die a slow death yeah and
it'll make you go home and it's such a
death that you don't even stand on the
back like you just go you know what I
got another spot some way yeah yeah if
you go somewhere by yourself for a while
I'd like that I'm gonna used to it yeah
like I got I died so many times in the
original room like the soul buddy oh
yeah I did there was like a 90 day
stretch and when I was adjusting to that
1245 115 spot that I was having doubts a
lot of doubts
that's a doubt spot right there but you
can't cancel it you're at the
world-famous Comedy Store is that if you
go outside and put a sign I got a spot
at 1:30 a.m. how many signatures would
be on that [ __ ] thing to performer
that's they line around the door so I
kept going up there even though it was
brutal and I'm certain times I had to
follow Mooney or
and my real nemesis that I could not
follow is that [ __ ] Dahmer out and
she'll put you behind these pen that's
you know it's rough while you're living
it but afterward you see the result of
doing those like even when I open flow
wheel Walker in December I that's back
to your roots that's people standing up
yeah before band survived
that's surviving that's just going up
there and knowing you have to do if you
didn't learn from Bill burr in
Philadelphia that's it you go up there
you report for duty you do you sing to
you stick to him that throwing [ __ ] you
don't miss a beat you just dunking your
barge bush nothing shoe sucking shoes
and [ __ ] I mean it's really a gift like
I said me Townes drive home that night
Terry and I in the car after we dropped
off our friends only can you believe
that's been 20 years of online
yeah how many people can you when did
you know Sam when you were getting on
that stage of Las Vegas did you know
with [ __ ] jiu-jitsu man from
headquarters
yeah Eddie Rafa no no no oh my being
Scott yeah Scott Ross
weren't you roommates with him somebody
I dude for ten years
yes I'll think about it did you ever
think I mean we would see people come
and go in this town leucine stars come
and go what made us think that we were
gonna [ __ ] stick it out uh craziness
well I mean we were just crazy we were
crazy enough to stay in it we were crazy
enough to be like when we lost it wasn't
the UH it didn't define us and we just
kept going now for me I have changed the
what the goals are you know I feel like
if you sit there like I got me this
isn't this you're gonna drive yourself
yeah you guys change every 90 days you
got a real friend you got be just like
dude I am where I am and I love where I
am you know I paid the lights are paid
this food in the fridge and I'm doing
this off something that somebody said I
would never be able to do people told
you that you were not gonna be able to
make a living doing it some of the
people the comics on the road going
don't move town you ain't gonna make a
living yeah I don't know about you guys
but between the store what did I and AD
I feel like I did pretty okay but then
you were the first guy to give me a paid
gig or a real show and then red band I
have the $20 he's the first guy to pay
me for a gig so it's uh it's cool I like
that stuff I guess I'm glad you're doing
it I guess that stuff would keep you
going like when you're saying like what
made you think do it for 20 years I'm
sure it has to get bigger it can't be
just 20 bucks but maybe in two years
I'll get to a future for somebody or
about five hours wrinkled up with two
drink tickets yeah wait till you get one
of those Li I've been paid and trained
$5.00 and for drink tickets and the
drink ticket to gold like in the world
of open mic comedy
I got drink tickets yeah I build Betty
six of them stomped on her body
like when Felipe and Willie Barcena ran
that room that was the main attraction
that they didn't pay you 40 bucks
there was drink tickets and you took
those drinks to hard track yeah you had
money a tip you were a gentleman but
there was a time in family or a drink
ticket like I used to get vouchers from
Mexican food for next week at what's the
[ __ ] place across marina hell Toronto
to Reno the El Torito and Colorado when
I first started I mean a 48 miles away
from where I lived on Thursday night Sam
I still remember like stealing nickels
like I was a car detailer and I would
steal a quarter from this car a quarter
from that car this car has three dollar
bills I take one you don't say it so the
guy goes I thought I had three but
nobody stolen maybe the wind blew like I
kept it like that just to fill up the
gas tank I get it to get me there to
pick up the $15 voucher and the 25 hour
payment and then with a five I tip him
and I put ten dollars in the car and
that last 10,000 II home with a smile in
your pocket you drove home with a smile
in your [ __ ] pocket one of the
craziest nights of my life what I was
paid in drink tickets I was hosting a
bikini contest at the Key Club which is
no longer the Key Club I forget the name
of it you're in Hollywood here in
Hollywood dude and you know I mean I'm
in my in my disease I'm drinking hard
dude drink take it drink Jax Jax jack so
the guy so we're doing a show a man and
I'm hosting I'm bringing people up and
this one girl goes for gold she [ __ ]
shows the monkey in the bikini contest
she bends over shows everybody where
babies I mean the [ __ ] gold and
snatch stared and for me that's all in
with ASUS you know what I'm saying
you're gonna got six Jackson yes yeah
your hobby one thing is I'm saying
you're not responsible they even tell
you that how the bottle of Jack after
fourth jacket you become Harvey
Weinstein
so I I run the whole thing they hand me
the fig I don't even read it cuz I think
I like oh I read it wrong she's number
one
I see number one I go and the winner is
number one I put the crown on her the
[ __ ] staff goes nuts the owner the
club at rig rig did his girlfriend
supposed to win and I read the wrong
name but I was so shit-faced right I
read the wrong name so they're like
wrong girl you [ __ ] you gotta get
that gotta put it on the right girl cuz
the owner's girlfriend was pissed so I
had to go up to this girl take the
[ __ ] crown off her and put it on the
other girl who'd won at that point two
giant security guards come and grab me
carry me out and when I say they threw
me out I'm not lying to you they threw
me out go you're banned for life from
the Key Club I'm like [ __ ] I get my car
I'm 19 because I can't believe it
I Drive a block I get pulled over by the
cops at this point I'm like well today's
a day we go to jail they go hey dude
what's up I'm like do you really want to
know they're like yeah and I tell them
the story of the chick who showed her
monkey and I hand to God they put me in
my car and [ __ ] gave me a police
escort home to my [ __ ] place and I
let me park my car and I didn't give me
a DUI that night and they made sure I
got home and that's a [ __ ] true story
because I made them laugh about the girl
showing her [ __ ] [ __ ] to everybody
to win a bikini contest and that's the
night I drank too much fun drink tickets
we asked for some sample what was the
craziest night you had a Vegas as an
open mic I mean you were though it's
gotten to staying open I mean dude we I
mean like like Stanhope came late are
you a living in Vegas I lived in Vegas
what we were doing for work I was a
waiter by day and I would do stand-up by
night and basically why you know I've
said this before but they're sorry one
more time what year is this well I was
are going college out in 92 you thought
of doing what I started doing I started
doing comedy and I started at college in
92 okay and then it was until about
three or four years later that I started
doing or I'd say about two or three
years later I started doing Stan
I moved out to Vegas because I thought
it'd be a great place to start doing
stand-up and luckily it wasn't and I say
that because I've such a crazy person
back then I was able to burn a bunch of
bridges and it didn't hurt my career
I've gone in New York I would have been
[ __ ] dude I would have us mean come
around I was a crazy guy it's like an
Armenian Italian [ __ ] just fired
dude I was firing I'm drinking oh dude
how the [ __ ]
no you know cocaine came a little later
okay cocaine but I love to drink and -
no reason
I love something weed but I was more but
I'm up booze I'm a booze and coke dude I
love booze and coke I love Jack and Coke
if you throw a little snatch in there
Sam's a happy man thank you because the
guy gave me a gift - gifts man gave me a
gift of funny and gave me three things
gifts a funny hard work ethic and I can
get [ __ ] erection on cocaine okay
that all the time oh dude rock-hard
Ginsu Nigel's
no-nos suck it again no no no it's a
gift that is a guy agribon no dude just
all-natural [ __ ] pipe dog and I'm not
a friend I grew up with it Union City
just recently dies and taken to a bunch
of Viagra you can die obviously he took
like [ __ ] 20 of these things oh my
god something happened I don't know the
exact for I was talking about this book
came out I called a friend of mine and
we were talking he goes you know he died
about three months ago oh my god
you [ __ ] took viagra and a hotel with
some chicken how many I don't know like
is there a number we need this nut
wouldn't even take one of those comments
Atlanta I would not well they say call a
doctor for last longer than four hours
though I don't want to even put what am
i [ __ ] him now people depend them to me
kind of to leave the handy boner pills
oh I got a guy you understand gross I
like just taking them at the guy see him
in like like black rhino and then it's
got some number I don't even know what
it means like 50 thousand kg and I'm
like what does that mean and then of
course cuz I'm an addict I like the pop
um and then my girlfriend finds she like
why are you doing this dude why you take
these boner pills I'm like honestly
because I'm just a
[ __ ] crazy person and I do take one I
think it's funny
you take them yeah I think I tried a
couple a few years or like way before
Paulo I had like for some reason I had
boner problems sorry I took a couple
then but I haven't like it was like it
was like I think it was even close
extend this is what I bought at CVS now
you're good now you got a mean one
oh yeah now it's fine now taking great
extends work shanky [ __ ] it what it
mainly I only took him like once I
didn't take it like to grow it like the
coach says to do but I uh it made me
feel kind of sick like it wasn't like a
great or if you take too much you get
your legs are [ __ ] up you get headache
I took one too much what I got enough
problems you don't say I am NOT [ __ ]
but you look the best I've ever seen you
more than anytime sleep I [ __ ] work
at it man I you know you look at all the
waste you have in your life time to time
like I love doing Tommy and I love right
that night but it comes with a price you
have to unwind if not you lay in bed and
you get more hyped up and now you don't
sleep so done while I watch TV but
sometimes you get into two episodes
ascent in a three episodes or something
and it's 2:30 in the morning and at 7:00
I hear somebody waking me up Dada Dada
Dada that you know and then you go do
something and next thing you know you're
[ __ ] wiped out after then you got to
do a spot another spot so I try to go to
bed earlier you know drinking water
that's it that's all you can do yeah
take care of yourself as much as you can
doing it don't do nothing you don't need
to do I don't never some guy called me a
1d store I mean it wasn't anyone for me
one I'm leaving the mall yeah what you
want to talk about again really beat the
bus laugh are we going up to a [ __ ]
table read and he's bobbing uh you know
it's like I'm preparing for next week I
got sick chosen done then I got Monday
Tuesday Wednesday under twenty two
things in three days and now I gotta
shoot an episode from
am i crying no not at all why didn't
this happen when I was 28
well I could snort through all this you
saying right like these next three
nights if I was going coke I'd stunned
it'd be all over
well I was out a long birdie channeling
not showing up you know I would show up
because the package and the envelope was
waiting for you yeah it's right there
them as soon as you land the Mexicans at
the hotel sitting in a chain nods a I'm
here already yeah and I'll be here
tomorrow at this time I love it you're
dying laughing that's like you're dying
up here you're yeah I got a recurring
role 3 episode that's right yes so I
shot one episode I shoot another when
they have shoot another one in March
that's great
so I'm super happy for everybody
involved is there great people is it
weird for you Joey gone what going back
to Denver where you do all that all
those drugs or no you don't get
flashbacks and I'm not at all I'm not
gonna baldness I don't have to two hours
of three hours to go to Boulder
so he's in seven Denver and whatever you
know it's so but I haven't no blood on
them
that's how Denver was a [ __ ] desert
when I was there uh there was nothing
there
once the Rockies came and they built
that Stadium
then all that built up around it they
built a new airport
I don't know this could end well I was
there I used to fly into Stapleton the
grayness Airport in North America this
what we're flying into tonight it's a
[ __ ] nightmare there's a three-mile
walk okay and then you gotta get the
claw forward it's a 40-minute [ __ ]
Drive those are the worst
Saturday we gotta get breakfast before
we get in the [ __ ] car that's a
45-minute [ __ ] drop and then you look
at it and you go who designed this truth
because if it snows your clobbered you
get stucked at that airports now it's
the Denver Airport
yeah it's shadiest [ __ ] this is anything
out you know this is what you it it
doesn't when you fly into Denver now and
you go why are we 40 minutes of
civilization
the big joke is you fly into Kansas
you're like why am i driving 40 [ __ ]
minutes in today it's ridiculous that
Denver airports got a lot of shady [ __ ]
involved with guys when you're
walk around look at all the artwork it's
very dark very beautiful the [ __ ]
that the best thing about that Airport
is you need for nothing
you can take a shower there you can rent
the hotel there you can [ __ ] work out
there they got a gym you can eat a steak
or you could eat [ __ ] Burger King you
get your nails done there's never a dull
moment at Denver International on it I
respect [ __ ] out that one time when I
gotta analyze that I was [ __ ] dirt
poor I got scale +10 no plane ticket
otherwise that I had a place to stay and
my friend gave me a buddy pass on
Frontier Airlines
oh god frontier that's like lending
somebody a pen to write a suicide note
yes sure dude giving somebody a frontier
buddy pass is just like saying to
somebody are you gonna kill yourself
hold on don't use the feather let me
give you a [ __ ] ballpoint either
saying like that's that's all that yeah
they lost my like I flew in like a 10
into Newark or something crazy and the
audition was it too when they lost my
luggage with the warm-up suit and the
whole thing so now I had a bomb when
they I didn't have go get a warm-up oh
man sneakers ah
and then the luggage never came no
luggage by the time I got the [ __ ]
dendrite picked it up in Denver but let
me tell you what I did I was so broke
when I got on that plane I don't have
any cigarettes and I didn't give a [ __ ]
I went right that delay it was looking
the other way I went right behind the
counter took a big gamble lights and I
went right in the bathroom with a little
[ __ ] saying I'm not walking no three
[ __ ] miles to smoke a circuit they
sold they sold cigarettes on the plane
at the airport Oh at the airport yeah
nobody do back in our day dude back in
our day cuz you're a young guy there was
smoking on the airplane and there was
this magical thing that said this is the
smoking section this is the non-smoking
section back and there was no no
complains Oh buddy got cancer nobody did
none those are the days where you would
get on a
and you enjoyed flying because there was
six other degenerates on the plane just
like you dog I was thinking about this
about and I'm not gonna say from where
to where
because then people people have to
[ __ ] say the truth but I'll never
forget what I was doing and not I'm not
gonna say that year there was a time
when I was doing super creepy [ __ ]
I was always doubled from Colorado to
Jersey and trading guns for coke then I
would fly back with the coke but Sam I
wanted a bender like I was a I stayed
clean from January 1 of 85 to about
April of 86 because a buddy of mine came
out
and said he was getting because the
snort this coke because I'm getting this
for this price one day paying for [ __ ]
honey and he told me I can make a
thousand dollars that's not even look at
it
thousand dollars an ounce did not even
look at it that's how good this coke was
so I started snorting he don't say my
without a [ __ ] aah I went on a
six-month tear it was like a six months
I slept five nights legit the other
nights it was like I did coke were you
either in that sleep or you sleep three
hours but it's cocaine oh yeah
like you don't even go deep into your
[ __ ] system so you're just walking
you're just a time bomb here the coke
birds here the coke Birds oh they just
[ __ ] walk in yeah good coke is like
good food right you're like oh this is
excellent it just disappears and you
know because when you do bad coke your
nose just goes and you're like oh [ __ ]
this is bad [ __ ] I just snorted [ __ ]
paint thinner right you know and then
you get that good stuff it just
disappears and everybody's feeling and
the ladies are feeling good and that's
all reasons do cocaine it's let the
girls let you do weird [ __ ] to them
they're just happy just to be on coke
and they're just like yeah whatever you
wanted to light me up and they're like
cool man you're like I love it that's my
problem the sex addiction I'm [ __ ]
coked up on a three-day bender and I
gotta play them I get on the plane in
Newark head it back and I sit next to
this [ __ ] chick in the middle that is
throwing the heat jack and then you know
how old talk
I'm coked up of shahi at that point I
was like okay that doesn't talk I don't
have blown the bathroom door little
bumps by myself oh she notices and she
starts talking to me and on this slide
she asked me do you got a blast for me
you go hold on one second I went on
behind the back like I'm [ __ ] the
whole time yeah took a little out
putting a piece of paper and I gave it
to a girl knock yourself out
this [ __ ] started jawing on a plane
next thing I always thought of drinking
next time when she started touching my
leg I'm like this is [ __ ] getting
weird here
she was bangin if I was
if I was 22 she was 19 20 she was a
college student somewhere and she was
sporting we were [ __ ] high and Mexico
I'm fingering her under a blanket on a
[ __ ] plane I never got a name on her
number that's all I have it was crazy
like it was who do you meet on a plane
and your finger them she was grabbing my
tachi and jerked me off and blow me
another like that nothing but it was
just crazy I was fingered this girl that
was the time I went to Denver important
my flight that Aspen was delayed nine
ounces on me so I said what am I gonna
do at the airport and I had I hit the
coca nose lockers where you keep the key
like [ __ ] get shorty yeah like yeah
and I would take like an eight ball on
the chunk and I would go to the barn I'm
just [ __ ] drinking doubles and those
days I was drinking that [ __ ] whiskey
and scotch
doubles on the rocks in an hour don't
touch the ice cubes I'll [ __ ] kill you
you know how much money I spent in
quarters getting that coke in an outlet
is the Dell announced at the airport
that night by the time we flew out the
next morning I was so [ __ ] coked up
that's where I snorted with this music
executive we got fucking's willed at
this Airport then they shut the bar down
at three Oh
so we're at this Airport coked up I mean
if it didn't stick out like a sore thumb
I don't know how the [ __ ] I didn't get
arrested that night we didn't lead from
next more than eight I was tuned up I
got on that plane tuned up I started
drinking bloody marys I thought I used
to drink in the daytime I think I'm a
[ __ ] now I'm gonna have a [ __ ] [ __ ]
out these drinks though yes and no we
had there was shot and [ __ ] somewhere
was that recently yeah I don't drink man
once in a baby blue blue blue moon I'll
do a shot Jack but I don't really drink
I don't like it I don't like I'm not
weed guy like I said once in a blue moon
I'll do shrooms just to talk to God you
know I was a conspiracy podcaster well I
like you and your part yeah
to being Ryan Davis tinfoil hat with Sam
Tripoli got got up to 120,000 last week
with our YouTube video and are on our
feet so we'll see how it goes man you
know I'm going well I never knew you
were a big big conspiracy guy I you know
I talked about this on Marc Maron's
podcast but I got in the kids spirit the
first times really knew those
conspiracies when the Iron Sheik and ah
[ __ ] hacksaw jim duggan got busted in
the car together do you remember that
and they were supposed to be enemies and
then they [ __ ] were caught drunk in a
car and I'm like oh [ __ ] there's
something up here dude and then my dad
always taught me believe nothing what
you hear and half what you see and then
I've so that I've always questioned
everything for me it's just like I just
kind of like I just enjoy knowing what's
going on it's not really that I'm trying
to solve anything or right any wrongs
I'm just trying to I just like to figure
out the game that's being played and
they interest me it's like I have to
podcast punch-drunk sports and I have
tinfoil hat and my whole days are when
I'm not working on stuff I'm either
going back and forth from you know ESPN
to read it and I just interest me I love
all of it I love all of it I love
hearing a bottle of talking about it
sometimes rub some people don't but you
fo not you I'm really in the money and
power corrupts that's my thing
you know Bigfoot stuff doesn't do much
for me I always said people hit me up
not really my thing specially be an
Armenian I say leave the furry people
alone them do their own thing right UFOs
I think there's definitely something
going on with that but I'm really into
the money and power corrupts Eddie you
know Eddie Bravo is the flat earth guy
we have this big show this weekend I
don't know when this comes out but we
have a big show this weekend Friday and
Saturday at the LA comedy club it saw
the Tim four ahau comedy die me Eddie
Bravo my buddy Reed Becker out of
Houston who says hello at the secret
group so the three of us are doing some
stand-up in Vegas late night for
conspiracy least it's a it's a woven of
a little bit I mean Eddie Bravo goes off
and it's fun to watch and I go up there
and I I i do my conspiracy stuff i have
enough in there that you know i can get
everybody Rocking
conspiracy theorists to a degree but I
don't have time to say I argue for three
apples well I get that like do you know
I'm saying like I could sit at home and
break it down by myself as they're
spitting it out at me but I don't know
my peers who are trust so how do you
like figure out who how do you figure
out what's wrong there's a lot of that
don't we like this show about Versace
right like I was down there with jim
Florentine as I was getting off the
plane checking into my condo they would
kill him massaging my head and we were
both in Fort Lauderdale Davie at the
time when they shot yes so uh I could
always I always knew there had to be a
by the way nobody comes up to Sam
Tripoli a beautiful gay man that holds a
clothing company in the middle of a
[ __ ] day and just shoot you and
creates his [ __ ] manhunt all over
South Florida yeah they had to be
something going on but guess what I'm a
comic I don't have time to be a [ __ ]
roving investigator yeah what have you
done yeah yeah you know and all of a
sudden RPI and all of a sudden I heard
little tidbits I used to work the UH the
Miami improv yeah time and I would have
and I would ask what's going on I would
hear little tidbits that it was crazy
what was going on in there
but it was just crazy you know [ __ ]
mansion in South Beach what the [ __ ] you
think was going man in South Beach
mansion like money keep money it was
crazy and at that time you know bad that
badass Club down there where on Monday
nights was there biddies busiest night
you couldn't get a flight from generally
and Manhattan into Miami on a Monday
because of that one club that the
gangster had the one half a gangster so
Miami was very very hot
oh yeah and they just killed this gay
guy through and clunk in the end that
wasn't mine I didn't know like I said
I'm not an investigative reporter you
know political stuff do you follow that
yes that's what you now you think he was
off by some powerful local people and
not at all I think he was off by a
scorned lover uh a scorned lover and
somebody who again had mental health
issues yeah you know mental health
issues existed the gate can be like in
any other community community in the
comic you know we should talk about all
the time that what we do is the thin
line of insanity
I mean when you first started coming
there was a place that you went to one
night a week that became your home close
your eyes close your eyes take your
sunglasses off the same episode of
magnum p.i close your eyes and think
about remember that place that he used
to go let the list was kinda long like
26 people on a list and you're number 22
do you remember that trip lady did you
ever go to one oh yeah okay do you
remember like number eight he came every
week he would wear like a handcuff under
a suit man yeah and he talked about
stuff that was normal and then um like
seven minutes at the fourth minute he
start talking about child pornography
and he'd start talking about the dark
side of child pornography and how it
affected me and you sit there and go
home oh this guy's but at that time
nobody was shooting people you know I'm
saying it wasn't when comics gonna take
a gun and shoot the [ __ ] audience at
that time right now you gotta be worried
because there's a point of standing the
store on Sunday nights twenty years ago
oh dude I've had so many glare remember
the old man that went after me that that
place is a thin line between they just
let you out of One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's right right you know and then
you look at the other side of it there's
another side like listen I've been a few
movies yeah I never wrote a show and
they were pitch the show right you don't
pitch shows ever but you know not
this time for 21 years I've had an agent
for the last five before that I had some
half-wit that I give him instructions I
do have to work the exam before who I'm
with now I just had guys that were poses
all they were were how was a corrupt guy
and they were the ones that made the
call yeah but I would call them and go
hey you did another thing about the I
haven't heard anything about it came out
two days ago and this mother [ __ ]
idiot don't know nothing about and I'm
wondering why I'm in Alabama opening up
for [ __ ] carrot top this weekend on a
[ __ ] Indian resort you know I'm
saying so I wish to [ __ ] push the
ages when you're a good manager when
you're a great manager by the time your
agent gets to the office at 10:00 and he
looks at his facts or his email you said
three mils or three rolls for him to get
on right let's go Lee you're not it's
not later then after you rub you now get
on it and I would call him at 1001 yo
what's going on I just got in drinking
my coffee all right won't when you're
drinking coffee call [ __ ] Jerome by
the casting in New York they looking for
a plumber three days on the movie I
haven't seen that yet not that where he
can grab a pen
grab a [ __ ] pen 1001 chop-chop I'm
saying yeah
I don't care about the 405 you should
have left 15 minutes ago yeah yeah you
know I'm up working since [ __ ] not
even better days it'll break now
yes did you ever get the break no I I
used to get them sorry but I you know
man I used to just go through the
motions in acting I've always just
wanted to be get paid to talk and I'm
doing that now and I'm really excited
about that I mean if I ever got
something on TV it'd be something where
I could just talk or like now I'm
shooting something with my good friend
right now
David dearie we're shooting a it's
called mad skills and it's a skills
video but of weird [ __ ] like you know
trying to if it's a zombie apocalypse
how do you get a gun you know you got
two grand but the gun cost five grand so
you got but your buddy has coke so you
buy coke turn the coke to buy the you
know it's like this weird fun that's why
I'm into I'm into talking
I'm not really an actor I used to get I
just never really cared I just love
talking well when I got here
my plans being a stand-up
because nobody wanted me Montreal didn't
want me no comedy agency wanted me there
was an agency I'm a gonna say the name I
don't wanna hurt nobody's feeling this
agency was horrible and I remember they
wouldn't even sign me the end saying
linking bad agents even guys that had
horrible reputations would pass on me so
I had to do the every 90 day thing I had
to go for the lowest common denominator
the hanging fruit as they said
commercial and I popped like two of
those in the beginning to put a little
zing in my nose
yeah and kept me in pork chops and
[ __ ] whopper jr. what time what's
Wendy's what's the one ds-12 Julia
yeah cheeseburger $0.99 menu in 97 the
to $2.99 thousand thousand that was my
little four o'clock snack everything
that you get cents with some fries I
lived up in a bowl of chili right there
right there you know what I'm talking
about right on oh they did not
understand me was it was $15 a spot I
would eat chili out of your [ __ ] you
understand me $15 some spot and
cocaine's a hundred a gram you do the
math I lived in my car but the best meal
of the day was an egg sandwich I would
get amazed if I would open up the day
with a nice fried egg sandwich was a
sunset sandwiches down the street from
me dock where when I lived on Hollywood
I got $2 sandwiches dollars egg
sandwiches don't know I would eat that
[ __ ] all the [ __ ] when I first moved
there mean Scott Ross we moved it he
didn't have money dude so we had to live
in a weekly which is one step above a
homeless person I'm not trying to make
fun of a bi situation but you know I was
blessed I had a little I worked really
hard before I moved I cash in my [ __ ]
bank account so we're working hard and
uh so this weekly it was so hot at night
dude I couldn't sleep so I just get up
and I just to the I still love walking
out I lived near Hollywood Boulevard
I love to walk the boulevard and just
see the people Maxwell it was nasty yeah
oh well that's why I loved it
I like the shady chef if you lived in a
weekly you live on like 5501 Hollywood
Boulevard
I lived Raider I you know they have a
hostel that does stand-up that hostel
used to be a weekly on Schrader yeah I
lived in there yeah I lived there yeah
you could only stay for like three weeks
in a row any one day you had to move to
a different [ __ ] hotel yeah let me
tell you if I ever write a really dirty
dirty dirty dirty book there's a couple
of chapters that but I will tell you
what happens oh let me just tell you
this real quick and then give me so I
would walk the Boulevard at night
because it was so high couldn't sleep
well one day Scott's working at the
Starbucks by the saddle ranch right he
used to work their way back in the day
with with other chick what was the
chicks name that moved to Christy Miller
yeah yeah misty Miller used to work
there so she Christie mill used to give
me hand jobs while we wait for show
she'd always give me a nice hand job as
a citizen cuz I was a shady [ __ ]
right so so we were hey wait we were
doing a Genghis Khan and they were
standing up there I'd sit down she's
done zip and just started [ __ ]
jerking me on and it was fun so any
wearable that's terrible
so a small of Brando type dude so we
were so I want an IV in Quincy Jones for
sure dude so I get a knock I get a knock
on my my door one day it's the manager
these two giant black guys I know
they're like you got to move out dude I
go what they go you gotta go
now I go why heels we don't have to tell
you I'm like okay so get my ass kick I
just grab my [ __ ] so I grab my [ __ ] and
then the two black guys are like oh dude
this guy is really nice what the [ __ ]
and I go can I just know why you keep me
I'm gonna go he goes yeah you're a gay
hooker dude you walk the boulevard at
night and you're turning tricks I'm like
no I'm not it's just hot as [ __ ] in here
and I can't sleep at night whatever your
gay hooker you gotta go so they threw my
[ __ ] on the [ __ ] aisle on the lawn
they'd thrown out somebody else but they
did not go quietly dude and they these
dudes were just grabbing this guy and
his girlfriend and just rode him against
the wall through them all my [ __ ] and I
gets there and [ __ ] yeah and then so
and one apartment on Schrader yeah then
they had the other one by the old Tower
Records up there
right up by where the pizza place is now
across the street from the pizza yeah
yeah yeah Lee you have no idea when I
used to get that Taco Bell money I'll
never forget buying six packages for 100
bucks from Chewie and getting the ride
from a little comic friend from Seattle
and stopping and getting like a 12-pack
and splitting it and I would go up to
him let me tell you something have you
just stayed there for six nights three
of those nights
somebody was nothing it though it was
creepy Lee it was creepy I had some
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] happen to me in that
building but I will tell you what else
that building I'm laying on the pin room
one day and the phones rang emember they
had a payphone yeah this is 97 is that
your view that's fine this one no that's
yours okay was this one yours no no you
backed out of the couch okay
it had to be 97 98 maybe I was snorting
up a storm
and some [ __ ] one night a chick just
nothing the door oh yeah yeah but I tell
you what else happened to me then I
heard my name in the afternoon there's
never Joey Diaz man but I'm laying there
watching the TV on that they used to
have that furniture that Lee the rooms
were a bed with like this old TV the
whole TV thing is like the Blues
Brothers status yeah it was dirty and
then had like a channel it was just like
[ __ ] up porn yeah but not really it
was just like we had pouring that ran
all [ __ ] there was just disgusting
and then but it was a room in the town
and I have to deal with anybody man and
they let you stay in there for 21 days I
was never in town for 21 days I was
always on the road that shirt really
didn't matter I wish it wasn't per night
it was super cheap like you wish you do
a week like um it'd be like a hundred
bucks a week so yeah I guess God
bodega on the corner across the street
to had a check cashing place yeah but do
you remember if you went a little bit
more west towards the beach on the
corner there there was a diner type
place but they were known because on
Saturday night they would do what a man
would dress up like women
drag queens drag queen karaoke Lisa at
lines around the [ __ ] block oh they do
that a Hamburger Mary's it's packed out
still over there because they let every
area used to be lit I remember going in
there one Sun on Monday morning [ __ ]
coming down off an Eightball with that
you know Sunday nights at the store in
the old days Lee Friday and Saturday
didn't matter the county stories what
you brought on Sunday yeah it was what
you showed Oh coach oh my god so much
fun I used to get lit up I mean I'm
about one night drinking that MDMA and I
was passing out and coming back to and
[ __ ] and passing out and coming back -
oh my god Sunday nights at the store
used to I love it - we give some
shoutouts real quick yeah hi thank you
some shoutouts first of all want to
thank everybody who gave me a birthday
shout-out you all did the family thank
you very much
55 died don't believe it you're looking
good dude we're trying the bone I know
people who look good drop dead the next
day put them a little gummy but anyway
Jesus thank you very much as a matter of
fact I brought them along with me look
at this right here this is a horn this
is a corneal and you put [ __ ] to my
look I put a Jew bowl open on it no I
mean animals I put the maloca onions
[ __ ] this is the Jupiter right here
anyway my main man Matt ho Maya
Randy Velarde the larvae
Donovan salad zoo saddle is a reuleaux
you know I love your [ __ ]
Lizzie Durazo keep writing don't let
them [ __ ] take it down my main
brother Sergio Vega
my other brother Danny beyond cool Oh
Lexus or Dewey
Mike main comic court
Gowan Joe Joe Pat J and that's it you
know I love all you [ __ ] don't
forget do not forget this weekend is
sold out there's nothing to do about
that thank you very much Denver thank
you
next week I'm going to Alabama and then
March 21st Nyack I'm going into New York
the corporation gets released on the
20th so I'll be in the city somewhere
I'll write you [ __ ] if you want
to come by and pick up a copy maybe TJ
signs before you whatever you want to do
I don't know how it's gonna go down I'm
speaking on a line anyway but the 21st
the next line I'm in Nyack at one of my
favorite clubs last time I was there
somebody heckled me they got up they
went to the bathroom five guys came in
and hit him in the head with a bottle
yeah I thought I'm talking about that
strange family strong you know I'm
saying that's diagonal and maybe four
did what's a--what's woody represent 607
607 for licensure my buddy Anthony I was
doing stand-up but this guy was just
heckle me and the dudes like my friends
like this kind of this guy who's a
family he's a friend of mine now but
he's like dude shut the [ __ ] up and try
to list this guy this guy's like I can
say whatever the [ __ ] I want
Oh drops this guy right this dude who
God Rob's girlfriend starts screaming at
me like I caused this she's like you
[ __ ] she I know you're CIA I
know you're FBI [ __ ]
and she throws her bottle beer at me and
I just go home just dodged it kept doing
stand-up as they threw the [ __ ] out dude
happens all time dog people come up on
stage when a rumble dude let's talk
about one time I was at the Comedy Store
and this drunk Australian chick is like
giving our Brody [ __ ] so Brody brings me
up and this time Brody did like the you
ever follow comic who like introduces
you but it's like a five minute
introduction where he's working a couple
more jokes as he's gonna you're like
let's go home boy let's go so I mean I'm
like Brody bring me up and like so we
had this weird interaction and he's
leaving
also in this Australian chick starts
screaming at me dude she's like you're
not [ __ ] funny laying into me for
five minutes you know all the [ __ ]
spot Alda guys work at the time so at
the time we're all a little emo [ __ ]
with skinny jeans couldn't stop anybody
right I
know where this white girl from the
corner gets up man walks over this girl
grabs it ghost enough of you turns her
around smacks her on the ass hand to God
picks his chick up throws it up over her
shoulders and walks this girl out a
block on this door at the Comedy Store
walks her down the stairs puts around
the patio tells her not to come back in
I'm like who the [ __ ] are you SEC I'm
just watching show I don't know where a
car full of five black guys this is a
true story
pulls up grabs this white chick throws
her in the car [ __ ] piss off dog we
don't know what the [ __ ] after that
chick good nothing good probably I'm
pornhub right now she's are the [ __ ]
on 170 you throw those little dirty
[ __ ] up there no one 70 buy that one
stop there yeah it's [ __ ] the rotten
[ __ ] corner this you know it's crazy
how many crap
wild things like I wasn't there for the
shootings in the white but I was there
like did you hear this story the reason
there is nobody everybody makes a joke
that the reason nobody else got killed
was kicked if aney had a shred the light
so long and the [ __ ] every time she
talked in the [ __ ] Rose battle she
would go on for five [ __ ] minutes the
show ran over 30 minutes late if Tiffany
Haddish wouldn't stop talking she was
shit-faced god bless the Queen she's
killing it but she talked that's when
the shooting happened cuz nobody was
downstairs because we were all waiting
for finish to wrap up or somewhere he's
at the [ __ ] Rose battle do comes up
boom and everybody was upstairs and they
never caught him oh dude they had that
[ __ ] setup they knew exactly where the
park that car so nobody could chase him
it's Nessa that's a great spot to shoot
I've always said the comedy school Jesus
do it is a grace Maathai somebody well
that's what these are about how they got
cameras in there now you [ __ ] unless
you know exactly where the cameras are
and we spray-paint the lens or knock him
down but the commies door would if I had
a beef with somebody I mean you know
I've been you know I mean and he said
you will you joke so he called your
mother fell like a down of time I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about you
had a get sent on a mission to [ __ ]
kill somebody but y'all to plan it out
like Charles Bronson the mechanic you
had to get him to the comedy store
because you know like within the
original mechanic Charles Bronson plays
I thought that's what they they just in
that's the resurrection whatever I
wouldn't see it but I know it's just
about a guy who kills people that's not
what the character of mechanic was the
character of the mechanic was to figure
out how to do you with the least amount
of damage when he got an order
it was either messy or we gotta make it
like you know like so he would look at
your records and know you had a weak
heart so while you were [ __ ] on the
beach he would shoot at you you know but
you're a bad guy anyway he would shoot
at you which would make you run and have
a heart attack and instead of shoot at
you so people would say we heard guns go
off but why did I have a heart attack
right just it's a different way of icing
somebody science but if somebody came to
me and they were like you know you have
to kill Lee and I knew Lee was an avid
comedy fan somebody says his weakness is
comedy he spends a lot of money up there
he's probably comedy he's [ __ ] one of
the young girls up there banging him and
he hangs out there on Saturday nights
with one bodyguard Papa's old iliza
shlesinger stunk that's where I would
Ganim or I would get him in the way of
if he's married I would you call his
house and say you won two tickets three
thousand come on down then put [ __ ]
the pay one of the waitresses to put a
pillow on this [ __ ] thing that makes
him pissed and stabbed into the bathroom
in the old bathroom in the original room
when you had get up and go back there
that was the perfect place to ice
somebody in no right there was six feet
back there
and it was always dark and the light
would bounce off the red wallpaper so I
would sit there every night dog in that
corner and watch comics and unless
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] unless the
comedian is not funny you would look to
the left Lee doesn't know which off him
up because he never saw the store before
they constructed that that used to be
wide open Lee no they put a table
against the wall that used to be wide
open she have to walk straight through
the main room so no matter how dark it
was in the original room that little
hallway there was gold if you wanna lay
some money it would be like that Xena's
conference I would make you get up and
as you walked into the men's bathroom I
would make Sam walk out and tell you
they're all packed in there you gotta
use this bathroom and as you made it to
the [ __ ] thing I'd pop out like
Pacino in Scarface for the friend you're
[ __ ] and stab you and Scarface just
stab you right there and just leave you
nobody would see it but the friend you
[ __ ] by that time it's 1:00 a.m.
there's maybe 18 people in the main room
they happen nobody the back of mammal
guy drops on he had a heart attack and
you walked out of there like nothing
happened
you put a cap on as soon as you hit the
door you all walk three different
directions or two ears nobody knows not
that nobody I was the whole way I used
to look at that whole way everybody
going boy I hope that [ __ ] like one
of my enemies is in the hallway one
night cuz I know exactly how to get this
but that was the heart and if not you
can ice them in the bathroom you got no
escape
you got no escape in that area trust me
I used to be angry when I first got the
Palin stuff and I would look at ways of
icing people like for years I would look
at different ways how would you ice
describe you Eliza just his homework
just to jog your memory you don't say
mister see if you still have read some
areas run the scenario I was watching uh
what was I watching Jota Jota and there
was his drug dealer listen you from not
damn it's impossible to get to every all
those guys have a mistress and they
almost saw their pissy to the highest
bidder well he was banging his mistress
they came out of the closet and [ __ ]
kidnapped right in front of his
bodyguards there's always a weakness in
their [ __ ] where there's a will
there's a way and you're right there you
know was I right that's what I mean you
gotta break that [ __ ] down no but the
Comedy Store was always like when I was
in my angry part of my life I got a more
than I being up there there was a person
a particularly individual up there who I
was on a find years later and I saw him
in the main room this is way before I
went off on it I had in my mind that
just dozed off and my cocaine craziness
if I was to ice this guy this is how we
do it
remember would oj wrote the book yeah
yeah if I was about to do this same
thing it's just stupid [ __ ] shame I
didn't do but if I didn't like that was
a book that's good
shanky people the main room by people
back in the day were [ __ ] all over
the place is having a Playboy Radio let
me know what happens well I this
basically wants to be big over there
yeah you they surround my show 17 times
a week we record myself Vicky
Gareth Reynolds Gareth went on to be
part of the dollop and the dollop is
[ __ ] killing it and then I would uh
you know I'm Vicki now doing I think
she's doing some a bunch of podcast now
like you better she's doing great yeah
she's killing it and so we've all kind
of it's just kind of hit you know we
kind of did I
you can only interview so many
transsexual midgets before you're like
I've done it you know I'm saying but
playboy the big thing about playboy was
that I think it became a a loss leader
for this company called mind mind geek
and my geek was this allegedly was this
company that owned all the tube sites
right you know like you porn redtube
pornhub all those people and I think
they were just making a lot of money in
the what happened was the big fallout
was that Sirius Radio wanted more porn
stars on Playboy Playboy's like
oh that's not our brand and this was
done by gentlemen I can say his name but
he made a fatal decision that in a fight
with serious he's gonna pull it off
serious radio and that was the beginning
of the end and they had the most
beautiful they're the best studio I was
on Howard Stern twice I seen Howard
Stern studio the Playboy Radio Studio
was just as good yeah how about that I
thought about the hell about a year ago
whatever happened with Sam being on
Howard Stern
I mean late this is he had a TV show on
Spike he was on Howard Stern tour I mean
you know this guy's bulletproof and
still [ __ ] the exam like he gets up
every morning like it's a wonderful day
to be alive he knows that there is
something in it he can't go nowhere that
we know we're gonna go who's gonna take
you now you're in it now - you [ __ ]
him what's the old dude that comes up as
the radio show on Sunday night Oh
the gentlemen of comedy fan Smith
craziest night a charity event with that
kid that kid that yeah that man he did
we did a skid row during all-star
weekend Charles Oakley growing up back
today
Nick's Patrick Ewing one of my favorite
players of all time
lastly yeah this last weekend yeah I
went down was meet Shaunie Shaun Joshy
fraser-smith and dude that guy
annihilated with these young people who
are in bad places in their life and you
know you go down there man you see
people hard times like we're dude like
we are blessed we did a lot of drugs and
we didn't end up there that we we had a
work ethic that was stronger than a drug
epic you know and that some people fall
through the cracks man and they're for
the grace of God go I so whenever I
asked like I'm doing Vegas this weekend
dude I'm flying back 9:30 to go to in
the morning at yeah I get back at 9:30
to do charity event I'm feeding people
you remember when you would go to Vegas
for town and you wouldn't even get a
return flight because you go was that
type of party weekend's like there was a
time
2002 to 2006 when I will have the road
like I would stay clean
two days before whatever odd because I
knew it was gonna be every night they
already were waiting for me
I knew exactly where to go they were
gonna drop a lot during the first show
on Wednesday night it was crying it was
just craziness like it was [ __ ]
craziness and now you're going through
these town Judy show you right back the
hotel room you watched my great sleep do
you sleep you read a book you [ __ ]
write jokes you know the old days I used
to sleep all [ __ ] then get up
hungover eat
I wouldn't exercise I wouldn't do [ __ ]
I would walk to the restaurant and
[ __ ] eat like that the cocaine
hangover oh you know me you would just
eat like to breakfast --is [ __ ] have
four slices of toast
every one of them had no it was things
like wanna vomit yeah the little round
thing a whole thing of loop you and I
would drink like freshly squeezed orange
feeling health in which in my mind would
make me be healthy what are you talking
about cocaine I drank a gallon already
this morning did you go for a walk when
I go for a walk I drink freshly squeezed
orange juice do you ever take allergy
pills for your runny nose so your nose
wouldn't be so blocked and then you wait
confidence like the the desert in your
nose just try cuz you don't really have
any problems you thought no I will
always take cope like hit my fingertip
with my finger and I will always dip it
in the coke and just shove it in my nose
and you give it a couple of minutes and
that's drain though that opens up
everything if it's real within two
minutes you'll be [ __ ] breathe and
smelling farts from 1973 you know I'm
saying this coke kid cold coke cures
everything she'll say no way about that
you get the bronchitis do a line rumblin
who gives a [ __ ] you took a flu shot
didn't you take a chance Columbus did so
he didn't matter like when I was in when
I was 20 21 22 it didn't matter if I had
a call it didn't matter nothing if
somebody hadn't won it and we have no
potential to get down the cold run away
right away that's why I know it's all in
the mind
because I lived through it that's why
when people tell me [ __ ]
I sit there man what are you talking
about I lived through it
I flew what [ __ ] flew and I'm not
gonna lie to you I ended up [ __ ] up a
couple of times I couldn't one Christmas
I was sick for three [ __ ] days I
couldn't move out of a bed but that had
been after six months of being out like
the [ __ ] album was kid Anthony
Sabatino it took me home and everybody
in those days do we took me home we
didn't know when I was gonna leave
I get it was I am like you took a chance
taking me to your house and feed it me
was I was Christmas and [ __ ] but I grew
up with Sabatino he took me to his house
and I laid there for three days I slept
that's how hard I was going I get yeah I
totally all the time twenty nine you're
worried about sleep at 29 I didn't even
know what a blanket was I slept wherever
right there guy had taken that for now
you'll be fine
tip-top Magoo you brush that tooth at
tip-top we go dog [ __ ]
you have no knickers oh my god girls
letting you get wet dude that was my
favorite just the thought of it just is
like I was such a fun time yeah it was
sexual harassment will you ring the
doorbell
that was my opening move like talk to a
girl ring the doorbell what do you mean
that's your opening move I like halo I
grab her close I'm close you know
there's some there ring the doorbell and
now you get do that [ __ ] no more teams
move like that no no no dude like you
got no one a bit when they want to seal
the deal you know you know that you
gotta go in you know chicks like knuckle
draggers they want knock the gentleman
knuckle draggers they don't want the
dudes running through the airport
[ __ ] you know crying about how much
they love them you know they want
respect but they want grown-ass men who
a [ __ ] caveman who are a [ __ ] show
some respect you know what they want
their own area girl for 15 [ __ ] years
dog 15 yeah I Google how to fake my own
death daily but I love her to death dude
I love her I love it will ya we've lived
together we got a dog who we I love that
dog Pollyanna stinks me jinx you know I
love that dog at the little
- she runs it's so funny to watch a run
cuz she's a little chunky it's I love it
did you ever dream you'd still be doing
this 20 years later you know man I don't
ever remember dreaming of like be
anything nothing like first grade dude
they didn't expect [ __ ] for me my
parents are looking around for the
receipt you would they you have a degree
yeah I got I got a degree from you and
LV I mean you're a smart guy I mean you
know I'm not a test taker though I could
take it I can put I could put I can you
you're you're the type of guy I could
drop you off on the corner with a dollar
and pick you up at five and you have 15
now yeah and you ate lunch yeah you
following me you figure it out and you
got new sneakers for yourself for sure
brought over five for Papa and you got
sneakers everybody's happy I was like
happy no that's what that's it I've seen
you like one of the greatest quotes I
ever heard about you you kept that well
I don't know what I was doing at the
time it was like every time you did that
[ __ ] show on a Thursday I was out of
town have my friend owns V Mac it's a
really good jiu-jitsu guy John Bud and
every time he does something I don't
either
off by an hour or I'm gonna for the
weekend we just did this weekend he's
got a great seminar over there I think I
don't know Joey Hoss and somebody else
and I saw an egg oh god damn it
I've been sitting in for three weeks
nobody this dick also I'm about to leave
and he wants to have a seminar that's
the story of my life so I'm surprised
I'm the only reason why I'm looking at
this thinking when is the audition gonna
come in there it is right there
No thank God thank God I'm sitting there
going what is the audition gonna come in
that they need on tape by tomorrow one
o'clock - really [ __ ] burn my craw
you know I'm saying and it's perfect for
me and it's not bad enough that you
gotta be on the [ __ ] stage at eight
o'clock at night and be and do two shows
on the Thursday Santa will tell me I
shoot something Santa is that most
auditions now they like put on camera if
you're gonna [ __ ] call me okay yeah
tell me put on dish
tape at 3:30 and Beverly Drive I'm gonna
ask you can I ask you a personal
question say sure
are you saying this still producers and
all producers gonna be in the room the
producers are not gonna be in the room
okay so I'm gonna go now they're into
Beverly [ __ ] Drive 3:30 for something
I'm not sure uh well guess what right
around the corner here on Laurel Canyon
there's a kid that you throw in there he
puts the timer on 20 minutes you sit on
the other side he puts a camera on you
he gives you one of those things that
you sing you know those conductors that
put music yeah you put your sides on
there and he tapes you he slates you you
do it within an hour you have your
audition that's great
right at the [ __ ] house and then you
send it to your agent all right and
guess what it's the same [ __ ] thing
it's the same [ __ ] thing so do it
and saves you 3 hours 3 hours I did it
that's how I got am i lyin here they
called me a year ago to come in for an
Italian tailor one day shoot for a
[ __ ] tail I'm a stand-up why would I
want to I'm a stand-up it's a stand-up
show right well when I'm gonna [ __ ] be
a tailor right so I said nah I'm good
thank you very much I'm busy that day
again that was one of those drives until
the mouth the hell you know I don't if
if I'm home for the week I'll take the
drink when I'm home for a whole week
isn't what I do podcast for people I got
time to spread my wings one day to
Wednesday hang um what story I get the
kids I gotta go swimming yeah I got
ballet tonight in time so yeah you just
don't have the time so you're just gonna
make me go down there's just from
producers for the pilot that we're gonna
shoot yeah and this is yeah real money
like they're talking yeah yeah I'm there
with the shoeshine right I got toenail
polish on my [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
shame I know my lines but I'm giving it
how I'm giving that how right now I love
those room
I walk in then there's four
[ __ ] in then I get them going
in there and I get them going before the
lines even come on yeah get laughs once
they start talking me about something I
take them through a journey of
psychological abuse and then the lines
are on and now even though I don't get
it they thought about me for two days
before they pulled the trigger story
yeah they pull the trigger they they
made me they they were like wait a
second
before we pay this guy sixty thousand
let's look at this guy again one more
time for [ __ ] the small and I'm
saying I uh I go on this audition we're
doing this audition we're just kind of
slate and everything and this guy's
having conversation and somehow it's
brought up like how do you want to do as
he goes I don't know man I think you
should do whatever the [ __ ] you wanna do
we had this [ __ ] in last week
this guy's dropping and bombs on [ __ ]
everybody and you know the producer and
the casting directors like you'll never
work in this town you'll never work in
this town your [ __ ] dad gets a call
from the director he [ __ ] book that
[ __ ] who do I find out it is
Joey [ __ ] Diaz [ __ ] is the
guy that they were talking about that
booked this [ __ ] gig and start
dropping and bombs in the middle of the
audition and the [ __ ] casting
director went nuts but the people above
them [ __ ] loved it and you got the
gig that's a [ __ ] real story I
[ __ ] heard in an audition for a video
game probably dude I don't know where it
is you start dropping and bombs and the
casting directors like I don't know
you're never gonna work in this town and
the directors like hired that
[ __ ]
it was audition you got to push the
envelope or dude but but we don't push
the envelope you're not gonna get the
room the director wants to see you push
the elf asks for forgiveness not
permission to go big in the hole I tell
people when they do to audition just I
mean for the podcast just be out don't
worry about funny just be outrageous go
hard in the paint God make them [ __ ]
have to look at you tends to mocking
right back in again Sam thank you for
coming on my class were you performing
again okay so tomorrow night Thursday
the 22nd I believe it is we are I'm
doing the naughty show Penthouse Pet
Pals presents a nice show live daily
coming up in the stratosphere I got
Kenna James pals pet we're giving away
top Co Vipers for all the ladies go and
then the [ __ ] next night Friday and
Saturday night Eddie Bravo and I and my
buddy read-back Becker
we're doing the tinfoil hat ComNet
conspiracies in comedy all night la
Canne Club 11:30 Friday Saturday night
go to the LA Comedy Club calm and
finally March 25th I'm shooting my
special at the Viper Room
it's called zero [ __ ] and we're
shooting two shows I believe it's gonna
be 7:30 and 9:30 so I think it's only
gonna be a hundred people in each show
so let let a brother know because I'm
ham picking these [ __ ] some
chicks like I'm bringing like five of my
friends I'm like nah dude you bring you
and one other chick do you know is dead
on the inside and is he gonna be good
and offended about anything I'm ham
picking every [ __ ] in here nice
touch brother vibe room I like your
[ __ ] style Sam triply let me drop
something on you and I'll let you go and
then you got things to do it's Thursday
you like joy what the [ __ ] you talking
about me talk about shaving all right
when I shave I ain't [ __ ] I handsome
dudes right I got I gotta get the most
out of my [ __ ] G this here you follow
me I gotta get the most out of my money
I love Harry's you like why Joe I'll
tell you why two blades the closest of
the shave too comfortable glide listen
Harry's is all about a great shave at a
fair price Y which is y over three
million guys have switched to Harry's
Jeff and Andy toured and every guys were
fed up with getting charged an arm and a
leg for razor blades they started Harry
to fixate to fix Jamie Harry stripped
out the unnecessary features all right
and the unnecessary costs to deliver
customers one perfect razor at an
amazing price all right so uh and all
the products are backed by 100% quality
guarantee a good shave comes down of the
blades because Harry's owns the factory
they're able to deliver amazing quality
blades for just $2 a blade compared to
four dollars or more you pay over at the
drugstore you understand me
so listen Harry's is so confident
you're gonna love their blades they're
gonna give you a trial shave kit for
free gratis nada free when you sign up
at harrys.com slash church you just
gotta pay for shipping no big deal
claim your free trial offer from Harry
tonight 13 dollar value for free when
you sign up just cover the shipping
that's it you get you got awaited organ
ama craze a handle you get five
precision-engineered blades with a
lubricating strip and a trimmer blade
are you kidding me or what
rich lathering shave gel five precision
engineered blades and a travel blade
cover who's better than uncle Joey I got
you covered
look get your free trial and harrys.com
slash church that's harrys.com slash
Church Lee look at me you're looking I
can see in the world we haven't even
gotten to Denver yet I can't wait to see
your face Friday you're gonna be on the
phone with mom thinking about going back
to [ __ ] Israel or something like that
anyway let me explain something to you
here all right listen Squarespace is a
tremendous I love it I love everything
about the idea everything that they do
you know what you got this idea in your
mind maybe you want to sell something
that you create turn your cool idea into
a new website showcase your work blog or
publish content sell products and
services of all kinds promote your
physical or online business or announce
an upcoming event or special project
listen analytics help you grow in real
time they got a built-in search engine
that's optimization with free secure
hosting nothing to patch or upgrade ever
and 24/7 award-winning customer support
you're gonna enjoy it who are you
talking about I'm talking about twelve
space square space does this by giving
you beautiful templates created by
world-class designers powerful ecommerce
functionality lets you sell anything
online everything optimized for mobile
right out of the box so listen what I'm
gonna do is this head over to
Squarespace calm you got an idea you got
an idea
let's go for it go to squarespace.com
for a free trial
when you're ready at lunch you know when
you're ready to launch right now enough
of sitting there scratching thinking
about the future what's gonna happen who
cares if you don't give it a shot
how you gonna know go to squarespace.com
use offer code Church and save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain that's it it's time for you to
make the move that squarespace.com enter
code Church I want to thank my man
boom-boom shrimp Lee don't forget I'm
gonna have a Bama next week
Huntsville I'm coming in big off a
[ __ ] plane with a parachute it's all
over and then I'm going to [ __ ]
levity leave levity live and [ __ ] at
NIACC the home of the witness relocated
anyway I love you [ __ ] I love
sambito of you too buddy you thank you
very much for coming on any time all the
time Lisa at don't forget about me you
know the Jews lovely have a great
weekend and I'll see you guys this
weekend and then the stay black
[Music]